hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
Leeds I am a property investor and every
single week I like to take an
opportunity to take a few moments to
basically answer your questions if
you're in property I want to help you go
further if you're not employed but you
want to get started I want to give you
that information
like content that inspiration to get
started so I'm going to take some
questions from last week and if you've
got questions comment them beloved a
whole load of comments below I'll read
them and I'll pull out some questions to
answer the next week so while I'm going
through these you can be thinking of
your questions and then commenting below
what we got Martin Martin Jean Dora by
the way I've been investing in property
for 11 years and I'm pretty successful
as well so just in case you wonder to do
the heck I'm all right he says Samuel ah
next time could you please talk about
how to deal with builders how to make
sure they do a good job and don't run
away with your money the whole process
of refurb description would be much
appreciated okay depending on the size
of the reefer depends on how you want to
play this if it's a big reefer but you
it's probably not if you just starting
out in property but it is a big refurb
you need a project manager okay that's
someone that you pay to just be on the
ground and making sure everything's all
good
I'd suggest using building companies
whereby rather than you finding let's
say you're doing a refit on a house and
you need the electrics doing you the
plumbing Dhoom you need some carpets you
need to this you know that rather than
you doing finding the electrician
finding the plant finding the decorator
finding the plasterer finding the flora
and then certainly what happens is
you're the middleman in between all
these builders and all these trades
people and then they'll get on each
other's way and they'll tread on each
other's toes and it's just it's just an
absolute nightmare you're better off to
employ a building company however
everything in house so they will just
basically manage the whole the whole
thing for you and you'll usually pay a
little bit more but it's so worth it
there are good builders out there how do
you find them probably referrals also
see their work
and you know if they've been referred by
somebody who you trust if you've seen
their work and if you've got a good gut
feeling about them then that's probably
good signs make sure that you have a
breakdown of the works absolutely
everything make sure it's all itemized
so you know and and how much everything
costs and there's a split up of maybe
labor they're at their time their day
right and also costs you might want to
see it you might want to see that as
well and also time time scales there's
only the two things builders usually do
wrong is they go over time and they go
over budget so you just want to have it
all written down maybe make sure if they
go over the budget have like a penalty
in place so look if it doesn't get done
by this date and they're that happen to
having to pay for that also don't pay
upfront you can pay upfront but don't
pay the whole thing upfront if the
building projects going to be 12 grams
and maybe consider paying four grand for
round four round and then saying here's
the first four grand and then when you
achieve this when you do you know this
level of works then I'll pay you again
and you pay installments never pay
never never never pay the whole thing up
front because even if they are good and
they are trustworthy what you'll find is
human nature kicks in and then not some
righted because you paid the hop you put
them up front for the whole job and it's
sometimes demotivating for them right at
the very end for the snagging of stuff
project management's always what is good
as well even if you don't need to employ
a full-time project manager but you
could just literally happen yourself or
have someone who checks up on them once
a week but you need to be on top of them
hundred percent if you're not if you're
not there if no one's there no one's
present then you're asking for troubles
so there we go
Builders time to help stunt frenchie I'm
seeing more and more homes for sale then
changing to let after some time on the
market
so potential lease option agreements as
you've mentioned previously yes how do I
go about negotiations with home sellers
having no experience no money to move
forward is it about making or closing a
deal then looking for people like
yourself or investors yeah potentially
if you if you look if you want to be a
deal packager you want to find deals and
sell them on then you might ask the
question what comes first the deals or
the investors
I probably just go aggressively after
both it's probably better to find the
investors first and then ask the
investors what they're looking for and
when they tell you what they're looking
for I would say great so if I can find
you something that's BIM Bom Bom
so it just like this would you pay me
three thousand pounds and if they say
yes then what I would say is well look
why don't you give me a thousand pound
deposit and then give me three months
and then in three months if I haven't
found anything I'll give you a thousand
pound back if I have found something and
you like it you can give me the
additional two thousand pound that's
good business because that way you
getting money upfront you're then going
out looking for deals specifically
knowing what you've got in mind and the
so many time waste is out there that
will say yeah I'll give you three grand
and then you find it and then they'll be
like actually just get the money up
front off them look for the deals as
well if you're finding good deals if the
deals are good enough the investors will
find you but it is a little bit of a
chicken and egg so hope that helps
oh and little lease option agreements if
you try not negotiate your sellers on
this option agreements it's really
simple lease option agreement is just
your bite now but you'll pay for it
later and then in the meantime you'll
wait for the appreciation to go up and
you'll get benefit from the rent that's
what it is buy now pay later he's just
you just want to speak to sellers and
just say to them look your house is on
the market for a hundred grand I can
either give you 80 grand which is what I
want to give you but I'll paint you all
up front right now so I can pay you what
I want to pay you but I paid on your
terms or I can pay you what you want
which is a hundred grand but I'll pay
out on my terms which is in five years
comment on the lease option which one's
best arranged geez just just speak to
people learn the skills of speak to
people stuff I do all day every day
parent as if I was a teenager if a
teenager was to attend the property
investors crash course with the teenager
have to be under the constant
supervision of an adult no they would
not ah Mendel Oh probably tried to keep
posting that buy-to-let is dead or on
its way to be dead
interesting to hear your thoughts on
this subject probably probably try I'm
saying it's that no it's not dead but
listen when people are saying the bytes
that is dead and the media is worried
and people are scared that is the best
kind that's when you should be greedy
why because when people are scared and
when the media is talking about how
bytes are dead or whoever then that
means that sellers are worried which
means that you can get a good discount
which means that you are in a better
position to negotiate when property
prices are going up whilst it's good
because you can buy and you know it's
going up well that's good actually
you're in a much better position to
negotiate when property prices are a bit
I'm sure and as long as you're planning
on holding them long term you buy low
and then you rent high and then you wait
for the caps and appreciation to go up
so like when the taxi drivers are
talking about how good Bitcoin is that's
when you've got to get out and to say me
property so I mean I don't know what
who's saying what exactly but that's
generally my consensus okay Stephen
Murray says counsel tenant or
working-class tenant working working
tenant I my strategy is for working
people and professional people generally
and however it's not to say council
tenants never make good parents some
people I've got some friends and some
students where their whole strategy is
around council tenants my I have a few
council tenants but it tends to be when
they've moved in as a professional they
never lost their job and then I haven't
got the heart to kick them out and then
there are benefits but yeah I think the
thing is if you are gonna have council
tenants just make sure that the council
pay you direct rather than pay the
tenant and then you have to
just hope that the tenant pay you that's
my experience all right raw team music
he says themes are good would it be
possible to book you Samuel to do two to
three days of training with some ghetto
youths no you don't need to book me to
come and do some training together use
because you can like my training too
ghetto youth will be no difference to my
training to 50 60 year old professional
people in suits because like property
investing is property investing is
property investing the strategies are
the same and I just think bringing you
ghetto yields for me man I've already
paid for the venue
I mean hey listen if you want to inquire
for me to come and speak you can just
drop me an email to info a Samuel is
calm but it's I'm not cheap because I'm
so busy but come on down come on down
come on down and I'm putting on programs
all the time alright last question house
flipping should you spend a lot on the
flip or keep it minimal should you use
neutral colors like new build or do
different colors with featured walls etc
okay so two questions there
alright firstly in regards to colors and
stuff I wouldn't do neutral colors back
in the day everyone was doing Magnolia
and light sort stuff but the thing is
everyone's doing it and it's boring and
I think the best lot the best hotels
these days are doing more a bit more
poppy it's more poppy you know like
white walls with a nice bright feature
wall I think that kind of stuff sells
better in 2019 and if you're buying it
to sell sometimes people want to put
their own stand point anyway but if
you're buying it to rent out or buying
it to refinance I think you've got to
make it pop you know in regards to how
much would you spend on a house flip it
depends there's three figures when
you're buying a house to refinance or
buying it to sell it there's three
figures that you've got to know number
one is what are you going to go in it
okay so what's the seller gonna accept
what's their bottom line so I'll always
ask the question when I'm buying a house
I'll say what's the lowest that you
could accept but still move with you
could get that lowest priced that's the
first figure second figure is how much
is the refurb gonna cost so you want it
nice like you can't cut corners really
on it on on a reefer but I don't think
because if you cook corners
gonna come and come back so how much is
it gonna cost to get it good to get a
good standard good quality so so say the
purchase price is 100 gram and then
you're gonna invested a 20 grand on the
refurb and then the third question is
what's the end value gonna be you know
how much value have you added to the to
the to the to the price of the property
and how much money do you have to invest
to do that and then it's just simple
maths you know if you're gonna buy it
for a hundred grand and spend 20 grand
on it and then the N values one to five
you made five grand it's not really
worth it so but if you can buy for a
hundred grand spend 20 and then you
could force the value up to 150 or 200
then then then it's really worth doing
it and typically you want to add the
value up enough to be able to think of a
new mortgage of seventy five percent and
pull your money out you know or sell it
and make a profit but there you go
there's general thoughts anyway guys
that's all the time for today I hope you
found that really useful comment your
questions below I'll do my very best to
answer them next week if you'd like to
come and do some training with me or my
team we wouldn't probably investors
crash course which is a two day free
training program and you gonna be on the
house so you can just find the link in
the description get yourself booked on
please do like the video share the video
subscribe to the channel if you're not
already a really appreciate and support
the more you engage the more videos of
you